[Music]
foreign
and I'm excited to talk to you about a
workshop that I'm teaching at this
year's posit comp in Chicago about how
to deploy and maintain models with
vetiver
turns out that lots of data scientists
and other kinds of data practitioners
know how to approach training a model a
machine learning model or a statistical
model there's lots of books about this
this is something that a teaching
classes at school however when it comes
time to deploy that model and maintain
that model in the long run as it
interacts with the real world there's a
lot more uncertainty and it can be
pretty daunting to figure out where to
start what are the tasks that are
involved
the term that is typically used for
those kinds of tasks is ml Ops which
means stands for machine learning
operations and I'll be honest there's a
lot of hype around that term around
Tooling in the mlap space what we're
going to do in this Workshop is we are
going to step back from the hype and
focus on the substantive concrete tasks
that you need to know how to do in order
to make sure you are deploying and
maintaining your model in a reliable way
we're going to focus on how to version
how to deploy and how to monitor models
we're going to use the vetiver framework
for this so vetiver is a framework for
mlops TAC and R and Python and that
means this this Workshop is going to be
a little unique in that you can choose
your own adventure you can come to this
workshop with a model or a type of model
that you want to learn how to deploy and
maintain
you can choose to work in r or python or
a little bit of both I guess if that's
what you want to do
if I were to sum up one reason why I
think you should think about taking this
Workshop I would say if you are Someone
Who develops models as part of your role
you are someone who trains a model who
Tunes a model's hyper parameters who
evaluates that model to understand how
well is it performing how reliable and
appropriate is to this use case if
that's you then you can deploy that
model and in fact you probably should be
the one to deploy and maintain that
model in the long run because of the
depth of knowledge that you have about
how that model works the constraints
around it so you can learn how to get
your model off your laptop and out into
the wide world out there integrated into
your organization's infrastructure
I look forward to seeing you at the
workshop